well you know how we we're officially
boomers now because we've held a press
event
with actual probably boomers that have
been on the same stage
as us they're like really important
people yeah
it's like a legitimate government people
oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay yeah we say boomers but actual
official
like political like important people
have been on the stage yeah right i mean
you can just tell i mean if you guys
went on to the fccj channel which a lot
of you guys did i think
we had like 4 000 people watching us
when normally i think they have like
six yeah they're only a lot of the
comments are really confused they're
like what is this can somebody explain
i think we were also really confused as
well yeah yeah so i guess we can explain
what happened
um what is the fcc jay connor the
foreign correspondents club of japan yes
which i believe is just uh essentially
the foreign press
yeah it's like an organization for the
foreign press in japan yeah yeah um
and a guy reached out to us who was the
interviewer
um called fred and he was like hey guys
i'm writing an article about youtubers
in japan foreign youtubers
uh talking about like depicting japan
and i thought too fair
that's that's a pretty good article
because yeah i mean i feel like most of
the younger generation are probably
getting a lot of information about japan
from
ours or chris or you know yeah i know i
know i know i got way more of it
from from that than the guys because
most of the guides are like oh you
should check out the kiyomizudero temple
in kyoto
and then go you know what i mean like
it's super generic no i want to see
someone like
do something really [ __ ] unique i
mean i mean like he asked us the
question about you know travel guides
right and i just i just when he asked me
that question i just thought
who breeds travel guides anymore no no
boomers
you say that but even my parents now
yeah they they've gone
they were like they were like i've
watched this this fellow
you know called abroad in japan
and even a lot of these travel guides
cite people like abroad
yeah yeah it's really funny now now it's
just instead of actually finding their
own [ __ ] like
chris found this really [ __ ] cool
thing you're going to check it out
japan youtube yeah but anyway so he
reached out to us and he showed us the
article
and it looked really legit and it was
going to be in number one shin bun
uh which is a paper here in japan yeah
um as as we all know we all need
we need a bit more like official backing
because uh two of us here
are verified on twitter everyone isn't
and the reason i got verified is because
i had submitted the articles that were
written about me and the interviews that
had been
that i've done but uh obviously someone
here had uh hadn't had any articles
written about him yet so uh but now we
got an article about cash
i have articles i just didn't submit i
submitted my wikipedia which wasn't good
enough for twitter verification
because was it the day that you found
out you guys had a wikipedia
you uploaded pictures for each other
yeah
we spent literally like half an hour off
this track just recording
just trying to update these guys
somebody somebody made a wikipedia page
and it's very meticulous and i was very
grateful for it and i was like why
didn't they upload a picture
yeah i feel like this is very easy like
just upload a picture yeah and then it
got removed anyway
yeah i was like i was like they're
legitimate looking pictures there are
pictures
yeah i mean we added each other's
pictures and then like less than 12
hours later it was gone
i'm like what the [ __ ] how do you get a
picture how do you get a picture on
twitter oh no it's
a wikipedia [ __ ] and uh yes he they
reached out to us and
he was like hey do you want to come and
give a uh do record a like pseudo
podcast
at this on this youtube channel yeah and
we checked that out we were like whoa
there's like some heavy topics on this
channel yeah i think the week he sent it
to something like lgbt rights in japan
yeah yeah that's pretty serious stuff
and then you want us to come on and just
clown and then ask
us about pizza [ __ ] crust i was like
you can tell that the trash taste
viewers were like had invaded the chat
because like we were having this very
official
um press conference and then like
i get asked about pizza crusts yeah
little anime yeah literally the first
question it was like all right we got
some questions from the uh the audience
right now and the first question here is
uh
god what do you think about pizza crust
i just find it funny how
just utterly unprepared they were for
like the amount of questions that were
going to be sent
because i remember the the person
running it just came up with like a huge
stack of questions
and the interview looked at this being
like this is more questions than i've
ever seen in my life what is going on
right now 20 pieces of paper she's like
here's the questions and the guy's like
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
it was quite fun though i mean i yeah it
was a cool experience and
we were like and the guy i remember the
guy was like you know oh you know it's
on a
official thing like you know fccj is a
professional thing that does a lot of
like you know press conferences and
stuff like that but like you guys can
just come casually because you know
we're just going to do it like casually
like you guys do in the podcast and
we're like
huh we're wearing that's bets we're
wearing the suits
i mean like we had there was that wall
of the previous people that had done
fccj press conferences because they've
only just started live
broadcasting them recently if i
understand correctly so but they've been
doing them for like years and years but
most of them have been private
and like we saw the dalai lama on there
miyazaki did i see trump on there as
well
like a very young trump was there like
[ __ ]
um yeah the ex-prime minister of
thailand i didn't know this because like
i saw
a picture there and i was like it looks
kind of familiar and i was like where do
i recognize him from so i
snap it send a picture to my mum and he
was like oh that's that's the ex-prime
minister of thailand so i'm just like
so [ __ ] only the important people
yeah [ __ ] brilliant
what's going on here and then imagine
that wall
and then the literal front of the fccj
building is this giant billboard this is
like
tonight on their ccj trash taste
and it was so [ __ ] weird because it's
like
we should not belong on this billboard
yeah i i think as well uh
the journalist fred was like i wanna
just be like a normal trash this episode
i don't think we can do not enough i
don't think we can just
cut turn up here and just do a normal
trash i think i think i'm gonna have to
be polite
like was he expecting us to like rock up
and be like oh you dk
yeah because like i saw a lot of the
comments be like this is the most
calmest and most polite i've ever seen
the boys well
yeah if you'd seen the stage that we
were on you probably act the same as
well honestly who was on this stage
before
us then you would probably act like that
as well i saw a comment that really made
me laugh and it was like
that that had the the watermen's doing
god's work
not a glass empty for a single second i
was so awkward as well because you're
just sitting there and then this guy
just creeps over
like like bent over and i'm like oh i
feel so bad for you i'm like i don't
need water
i was like why are you topping me up i'm
basically full
yeah awesome awesome jerry why don't you
have to go to the toilet
mid sentence you couldn't have like
waited until you finished
hilarious okay like i dead ass was like
holding on to that [ __ ] for dear life
you could have done it before you
started the sentence 30 minutes
you started the session i was like i was
like i'm going to go for as long as i
can
and i think about an hour into because
it was like a two hour yeah
about an hour and 10 in i was like i'm
going to die
like my bladder is about to explode
before but i can hold on it's like 50
minutes if i just concentrate
on talking and just listening i can get
through it
and i got i didn't forget what else what
questions did i get
you are actually getting asked like a
serious question in the middle of a
serious question and you're just like
sorry can i go to the toilet yeah yeah
did you even finish your like you just
went and i was like
what the [ __ ] like i literally got like
mental whiplash because i was like oh
this
is uh joey being pro premium and pop
proper and professional
but now no way just busts out the can i
can i go to the toilet you can hear the
very moment my heart just snaps and i'm
just like
you have to go i was like i'm going to
cut this into short i have to [ __ ]
otherwise i'm about to piss on stage in
front of four thousand people i'll be
honest when you asked to go to the
toilet i looked to you and i was like
should i do it should i do it no hold
on hold on i was like oh did you guys
and i'm like i can't be the only one
who's busting for a piece like
like inside like my my leg was like
going on like [ __ ] sonic speeds
it was just like come on come on i was
like i was like water boy if you come
near me one more time i fill up that
glass i'm going to kill you
i've stopped drinking water for the past
30 minutes because if i drink one more
sip of water i am going to explode
stop filling up my glasses can you help
me the bottle
just give me a bottle boss man i just
drink in this slowly
this is gonna be a really question but
can you can you uh could you get under
the table
[Laughter]
yeah no i could have man i was like i i
was like do i
just ask the question or do i piss on
stage i'mma ask the question
[ __ ] it he said he was like yeah this is
the first time it's ever
happened in the history of the fccj or
something right i'm like [ __ ]
there's gonna be another asian person
surely
or i made history by being the only
person there's a lot of people who made
history
a lot of people made history on the fcc
j but no one's ever taken a piss break
in the middle of one
i gotta ask what did you guys write in
the guest book because uh i
remember so we had to sign a guest book
right right
so every guest who's been on there has
like right sign it and write some kind
of message or something
and we we had some really like deep
important messages you know some talking
about some
very you know hot political topics right
now some people
some i think one message i saw was said
something like
we must listen to the voice of the
people yeah the people
will not go unheard and there's only so
long that we can stop listening to them
and so or something along those lines
and then i turn the page and it's just
my message being like
senjighara best girl giggot 2021
at least like you came up with like a
kind of funny one like
i saw that and i was like i can't top
that why wouldn't you write
i think i wrote something like i like
anime yes i do
only only the biggest is that the same
thought process that you went through
when you
came up with the anime yeah literally
yeah i like yes i'm doing anime yes i do
joey the anime 2021 i just put i don't
know what i'm doing here
it's literally all i write i mean that's
probably the most honest that's probably
the most
i don't know what i'm doing here connor
it was a great experience it was super
weird to be on something
that official and i don't don't even
think like our fans knew how official it
was
um what they were watching we didn't
even say anything about it until like 10
minutes before we like should we tweet
out that we're doing this yeah
it's been live stream yeah now it's the
most viewed video on their channel
as well probably by the time this video
is live it's well over half a million
views
i think so yeah i mean it's pretty
insane i mean it was just basically like
a trash taste episode but just
like polite yeah the gentleman i did
like all the memes which are like oh
damn
pogba the new studio center all the
budget yeah
that's where all the budget went yeah it
wasn't the trash taste episode it was
the garbage taste episode
i remember i saw i saw that camera and i
was like i was like weak
what a weak camera one one camera angle
one camera oh this is a
sony handheld what is this
yeah i was like where's the lights where
where's the lighting come on come on
look
look at this i like this this floor has
a restaurant in it you guys can afford a
restaurant but not a good camera yeah
seriously come on come on
i'm kidding yeah we were really we were
really honored to be invited on that and
yeah we realized much like i think it
kind of set in much later
i was like oh i think we actually did
something like pretty cool and legit
yeah no i think it's i don't know how
many youtubers can say they've done
something like that
and uh i think we did a good job we
didn't embarrass ourselves too much yeah
yeah i'd say so i'd say we were i mean
we were way more reserved than
on our usual you know [ __ ] monkey
mode podcast or whatever
but uh yeah it was a great experience
and
one of the things we've been doing in
between building this set
i guess yeah